the fans are out in force today and it
is time for baseball
and today it's the new york yankees
against the new york mets in the first
game of a three-game set the subway
series
jordan montgomery towing the slapping
the boogie down here on a
overcast afternoon no rain right now so
i think we're okay
to start you can see his numbers 23
walks and 80 strikeouts
nine homers giving up here you are
setting up the mets with an opportunity
here in the first inning
swing and a miss big strikeout of
dominic smith one away
really worked him over with curveballs
away then he went down and in on a
couple and then
finished him off with a change up kind
of ran out of options
but a good pitch there and a huge
strikeout was not looking for that one
he would have got me too
here's james mccann and the 2-2
struck him out swinging a change down
into a good pitch
for the mets no runs one hit two left at
the end of a half
the mets nothing yankees are coming
about well taiwan walk for you i told
you that uh
in his starts jordan montgomery the
yankees are eleven and four well they're
11 and three
and walker starts no decision in his
last start against the phillies five
innings
one run plenty of rest for that good
fastball and so with two out nobody on
gary sanchez the better and he's not
quite the turnaround season one two
pitch
fast ball in there strike three call
side retired
walker gets the yankees in order and at
the end of one the mets nothing the
yankees nothing
carlos stanton leads off in the home
second he hits the ball harder than
anybody else in the game
and it's on the outside corner walker
does a great job
picking off the outside edge against
stanton as he did against sanchez
and his back-to-back fastballs with two
strikes he's so far off the plate
keith i don't know if you paint that all
night there's no way he can hit her all
afternoon
torres at first with two down now here's
georgella
rochella takes strike three call walker
with his third strikeout and that ends
the bottom of the second no score
back-to-back one-out hits for lindoran
smith and the mets have something
working in the third
so here's pete alonso first and second
one man out against montgomery
top of the third inning at the stadium
swing and a miss he made his pitch
a four-seam fastball two-way a very big
batter and a very big pitch
runners lead at second and third two out
it'll be a one-two to mccann
man the pitch is strike three is a
breaking ball
and mccann didn't like it in the inning
no runs two hits two level
end of two and a half no score so one
out nobody on brett gardner the batter
now
and he drives this one toward the left
field corner but it's run down by pilar
that expanse of left field at yankee
stadium it's good to have
somebody like pilar over there in the
corner they also have pilar
shifted to the left field line look at
gardner he's like how can you play me
there
no get it because off the bat he had to
think uh that was going to be a double
or a triple watch
come on
oh we've been there well gardner has
become
an expert over the years of banging that
top of the dungeon sometimes with a bat
trying to take something out light bulb
hit the fan whatever
roll for five with runners in scoring
position dom smith at a base hit his
last time up
let's hit on the ground toward the whole
base hit around third comes nimmo
and he'll score in the first run of the
game dom smith found the hole
he's got an rbi single and the mets jump
in front one nothing
second hit of the day for dom they did
not put the full shift on against him
and he found the hole up the middle hit
him where they where they ain't
and that's just smart hitting on a
slider right there away
that's normally a double play ball but
with the shift
doesn't work for the yankees this time
and dom
continues and welcome back brandon nimmo
right in the middle of things
so nimmo three at bats off the injured
list three line drives two hits
and dom this time able to cash him in
when doors at third smith
is at first and the three two he walked
and that will hold the bases and bring
up a cam
now that's a slow walk by aaron boone
and he does make a signal for lickey
one run in the mets have the bases
loaded with one out the yankees going to
the bullpen
here in the fifth can five career grand
slams mets don't have one this year
he breaks his bat he bloops one into
shadow center and falls for a base hit
lindor is in everybody else moves up a
base
at the cost of the back james mccann
drives in a run and it's two nothing new
york but not hitting it
particularly hard but getting the job
done
so the bases remain loaded two-nothing
match galore has been up twice flight
out both times
when you that gets away from sanchez and
here comes smith now it matters what dom
does
he steps on home plate and it's
three-nothing match
well sanchez with the backhand i believe
fastball earlier and now
unable to block the wild pitch by litki
with the bases loaded and that brings in
the third run of the inning torres will
be running dom playing behind him
and gardner smacks one out to left
center field back in the gap
goes pillar to grab it and that retires
the side
good at that for gardner but walker's
now got five no-hit innings under his
belt in a three-nothing lead
the mets have the bases loaded and
francisco lindor coming up three-two
coming
and lindor lays off did he swing he did
not ball four and it forces in the run
four-nothing mets well wilson will get
one more batter with dom smith coming up
he bats here with the bases loaded still
nobody out
and he slashes that one down the left
field line that's a fair ball going down
toward the corner
peraza is in nemo scores stopping a
third as lindor
it's an opposite field two-run double
for dom smith and now the mets have
broken it open they lead six
nothing and that's going to be it for
justin wilson who faces five batters and
retires none of them against his old
team
so the base is loaded for pilar who'll
be the ninth man to bat in the inning
hit on the ground sharply and through
the hole in the left field a base hit
it is lindor smith right behind him he
will score
kevin pillar cashes two more as he finds
the hole on the left side
and it's eight nothing nets so the mitz
putting the hammer down
after king had gotten a couple of
strikeouts worked around conforto and
pillar
cashes two here's aaron judge he's over
two
high fly ball deep right field
comfortable back he's on the track
at the level for judge
first hit for the yankees first run for
the yankees
all rise there comes the judge
got plenty of leeway with a seven run
lead but i think he's going to make the
move right now
another tremendous effort for taiwan
walker so castro
against hershel bases loaded two outs
bottom of the six
eight one nets and the pitch
laced in the center field basically
stanley scores here comes he'll score
it's amazing to me sometimes coleman's
pitchers kind of out think themselves
here's a guy who throws 99.
they're four consecutive sliders and
sooner or later you got to put one in
play
and this has been the case all day kind
of another dumper just in there this
time goes for the yankees
can't let this ending end though got to
keep it going it's still done
still that
while michael king comes out to pitch
the ninth at 1-2
did he go yes he did peraza down on
strikes
seven strikeouts for king the o2
swing and a miss strikeout number eight
for king and that's in four innings of
work well he's had command with that two
seamer
into lefties break it up to the inside
corner and in
and off the inside corner off righty so
he's able to throw that sinker
to both sides of the plate and that is
so important
and the pitch is covered on him so
michael king in four innings struck out
nine men
yes this is his calling bottom of the
ninth inning
at yankee stadium that's eight yankees
three bruce smith stays on to start the
ninth
and you can hear the met fans drowning
out the yankee fans now
they're loving it and duhar hits one on
the ground ranging wide as dom
to drew smith to smith for the final out
as the mets draw first blood against the
yankees
as the mets overwhelm the yankees 8-3